it is the beginning of November 2022 so
it's time for another monthly update
video in which I'll talk about what
we've got coming up this month of
November and everything that we did in
October that you might have missed I
always like to begin by highlighting
three big things so big thing number one
for this month is I've got a new light
Hall class coming up on Wednesdays
starting mid November with light Hall so
you can check out the link for that
below I also shot a video about it and
there's a link to that as well
second big thing tomorrow I will be
giving a talk at the University of
Wurzburg of course this is going to be
virtual I'm not flying over there to to
Germany but I'm giving a talk on
Epictetus that is open to the public so
you might want to check that out and
then the third big thing is I have
started doing YouTube channel
memberships so you know if you've gotten
a lot of benefit out of the kind of work
that I'm doing and you want to give a
little something back you can do that
there's also some perks for people who
are becoming members including some
member only exclusive things you can see
the link to that below as well so with
no further Ado let's talk about October
the biggest thing for the month of
October was the international online
stoicon conference which we just
finished up with last weekend we've been
releasing videos from it as well uh so
people who weren't there could it you
know virtually attend after the fact and
get to see the the sorts of talks and
workshops and panels that we had so that
was really cool a lot of work
fortunately I didn't have to do it on my
own my wife Andy Shaka my good friend
and colleague Harold coveley and our
Tech person Philly yanov all contributed
to the event and then we had a lot of
great speakers and
moderators and panelists so so that's
that's a big high point I also did an
interview with my co-host Dan Hayes in
the wisdom for Life show of the YouTuber
herniades who has a new book out which
is uh quite cool and getting to talk
with with them about not just the book
but skepticism and cost-benefit Analysis
and all sorts of other cool topics on
the wisdom for Life show I did my usual
Hegel things you know the public chat
and the uh patreon exclusive chat I also
held an AMA I had to put off the Philip
K dick worlds of speculative fiction to
this month that's that's coming up and
I'll talk about that in the November
session but I did also do an invited
talk for the Midwest seminar in ancient
and medieval philosophy called virtue
without the mean the stoics on virtues
and vices and so that was that was quite
cool you can see the video for that
below and you know what else was going
on this month well you know usual class
related good stuff I've got four classes
running right now three at Marquette
University and one at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design I also got
my classes for next semester from
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
I'm going to be teaching an intro to
Humanities as a face-to-face class on
campus and I'm teaching a online
asynchronous class on philosophies as
ways of life where we actually do some
experimental work called philosophy
mindfulness and life so that's that's
pretty cool I got some writing done as
well in medium and shot a lot of videos
produced a lot of videos released a lot
of videos core concept videos for my
classes on anger on Joseph Butler's
sermons on Thomas Aquinas and on
seneca's on anger that I've been
releasing of course there's the event
videos virtue without the mean the
wisdom for life
I released a half hour our Hegel video
that I shot the previous month evil
Sadler also came out for a moment and
and had some crazy stuff to say I did a
Sadler stories video one of the Q a from
my light Hall sessions on Aristotle uh
what else I I did have some found
footage which was kind of cool
um you know my my massive hard drive
failed and so I had to go back to the
older hard drives and I found
some stuff that allowed me to um
create some new videos from some older
things so I patched together the video
recordings from when I interviewed some
of the key players in the institute for
Saint Anselm studies and released that
as the story of the The Institute for
Saint Anselm studies I also found a
video footage of a talk that I had done
in 2016 here in Milwaukee on
understanding Anger from stoic
perspective so I I released that as well
podcast work
I did a number of podcast episodes to
get them all out on epictetus's
discourse I think it wound up being a
playlist of 45 all together some of
which I'd done previously and and many
of which I did this last month and then
uh some stuff on Arthur schopenhauer's
on the basis of morality most of which
have been released at this point so that
is what went on in the long month of
October
what is coming up in November well we're
starting off really strong early on with
two events tomorrow that is November 2nd
one of them is virtual that's one the
one that I mentioned in the three big
things I'm giving a talk virtually in
this series on um you know philosophy
and reasons and moral uh moral activity
and stuff like that for the University
of Wurzburg which if you don't know is
in Bavaria not all that far from where I
was stationed back in my military days
over 30 years ago when I was quite young
and I'm talking about Epictetus on proy
races and giving reasons and and
rationality so that should be quite good
we've got plenty of time planned for it
I'm gonna do some talking and some
explaining then we'll do some q a and
discussion and they said that you're
welcome to join if you would like to so
the link is is below it's a zoom link
then if you're here in the Milwaukee
area I will be at 6 p.m at the Frank
Weinberg Library closing out the year of
the philosophers in the midst of History
discussions with a talk on Maurice
Blondell if you know uh my background
you know that he's the person I actually
did my dissertation on and I've I've
done you know quite a bit of writing
over the years and some translations of
him so I'll be talking about where he
figures into the complicated history of
the 19th and 20th centuries um so that
that should be quite interesting then uh
on the fifth Saturday at 12 p.m I'll
have my ask me anything session you know
you can pop in and get some questions
answered provided you get them in early
enough because we always wind up with
more questions than I can answer later
on that day at 2 pm we'll be having our
patreon exclusive philosophy chat we
always have some great conversations in
that
um on the ninth at 5 PM we'll have our
public Hegel Q and A and discussion
session so if you've got questions about
Hegel German idealism you should pop in
for that put it on your calendar
on the 12th at 10 A.M I'm going to be
showing up for
a stoicon x Midwest where I will be
doing a fairly short talk about uh
stoicism and religion and you know the
multiple different ways people
understand religion and the ways people
analogize stoicism to a religion along
those those lines so you can check that
out uh on the 19th we'll be having our
worlds of speculative fiction that was
originally scheduled for this month on
Philip K dick we're going to be talking
about Androids and humans so obviously
the Android's Dream of Electric Sheep
and you know some of his essays but
we're also going to be looking at we can
build you and a few other stories as
well the simulacrum that that should be
a lot of fun uh so we we start off with
a
premiere of a video with live chat and
then we finish up with some more
interactive discussion on zoom
on the 24th 6 PM we'll be having our
Milwaukee stoic Fellowship I'm not quite
sure what we'll be discussing maybe some
you know wrapping up from stoicon and
the various stoicon X's or there might
be something else that we we go into and
then on the 26th at 12 p.m I'm going to
start resuming those political theory
and practice discussions that's a live
chat with me sort of like an AMA but
it'll be much more focused on a
particular topic so that's all the stuff
that we've got coming up as far as
events go uh videos I'm planning on
continuing on with seneca's on anger
I've already released six videos in that
series there's a number more for me to
shoot on this classic stoic text I'm
also going to be doing some on Saint
Augustine uh you know some stuff
probably from City of God discussing uh
emotions and the stoics and where
Augustine thinks they got some things
wrong I also want to do some on John
chrysostom's sermons on Matthew and on
Ephesians that have to do with anger
resources for my students but also you
know hopefully for all of you I'm going
to be getting back to doing Hegel now
that stoicon is behind me I can start
getting back to shooting half hour Hegel
videos that I've I've neglected for a
while I also have a lot of books piled
up that need to be reviewed so this is
the month to get cracking on those if I
have time I'll shoot some personal
videos and maybe a caption contest or
another Sadler's story but we'll see how
much I can actually feasibly get done in
that time I also do have this class uh
that if you're if you're interested in
you and you want to read platonic
dialogues I am going to be going over
five platonic dialogues uh on Wednesdays
um you know sort of sort of a fun thing
to do 90-minute sessions we'll start
with
um the ion shortest dialogue and and one
that uh kind of gives you an idea what
this Socrates guy is about and why the
poets were ticked off with him then
we're going to run through the stuff
that you find in like you know the last
days and Death of Socrates so you know
the euthyphro the apology the uh Credo
and then we're gonna spend two weeks on
the Fado but not all of those weeks are
going to be in November obviously we're
going to begin about Midway through and
again you can see the link to that below
if you want to check it out
um what else trying to get some writing
done as well and
um you know there's there's odds and
ends that need to be tidied up uh
particularly after stoicon we're still
releasing videos there's still uh
stoicism today post to to bring out
um the podcast I am continuing on with
the schopenhauer on the basis of
morality uh podcast episodes uh I've
also got some on Audrey Lords the uses
of anger which I shot some videos on
earlier this year and I'm going to be
bringing those out and then we're going
to turn to Bishop Joseph Butler and his
two sermons that have to do with anger
and after that we'll see where we go
from there I've got a lot of things that
can be turned into good Sadler's
lectures podcast episodes so it's just a
matter of putting them together and
doing the editing work so that's it for
or November I hope you can join me for
some of these online events and uh you
know if you're in the area I hope you
can show up for the Blondell lecture
that would be really fun and if you do
you know of course come up to me and
introduce yourself afterwards otherwise
I'll see all of you somewhere in The
Ether over the course of this month have
a great month and I'll see you then